khiển để ăn không sảo của chính phủ về phát triển đứng dụng giữ liệu dân cơ.
Đình zanh và sát thực định từ phục vụ chuyển đổi số quốc gia,
phòng cạnh sát sảo thông.
Công ăn thành phố Hàn Nội đã tích cực chiến khai các sải pháp đổi mới trong công tác đăng ký,
khoảng lý phương Việt lấy người dân làm Trung tâm phục vụ.
Thay vì đến chức tiếp kế khai hổ sơ dễ như trước đây,
người dân hiện có thể thực hiện tòàn bộ thu tục đăng ký sế lần đầu qua công dịch phủ công bộ công ăn tại để chi.
Hát để tế bây, hài chấm, hài chấm, vẻ chấm, dịch vụ công chấm bộ công ăn chấm gửi ông về chấm viêng.
Các buức như khai bảo thông tin, lột lệ phí trước bà, lột tin lệ phí đăng ký sế, bấm bình số,
đăng ký lệ khệ điều đục số hóa, dút xuất nạn thời gian giám xa sốt, tiếp kiểm si phí đi lại.
Sau khi hoàn tất hổ sơ, người dân có thể nhận kế quả chức tiếc tại cơ sơ đăng ký hoặc qua biểu định tại nhà.
khi nhận kế quả, cân nộ phíu kìm chá chất lượng xuất sử, bối xay sản xuất, lắp giáp trong nước, kèm bản cả số mái.
số hong có đong dấu giáp lại của cơ sửa sản xuất và giấy chiếm nhận chất lượng ăn tòa ký thuật và bảo vệ mua chương.
Bối xe nhập khẩu. Hoặc thông bảo miễn kìm chá chất lượng, kèm bản cả số mái, số hong có đong dấu giáp lại của đất vị nhập khẩu.
Chình đổi số trong lính vực đăng ký xe giúp năng cao hiệu quả quả lý phương tịch, đồng thời.
Khi chính xử lượng nghiệp vụ được thực hiện trên nền tàng giữa liệu định từ,
nhang chấm, khoa học, vóa phần xây dựng nền thành chính phục vụ hiện đã.